la bouche ça les oreilles Jennifer voilà
bouge-toi les oreilles ta mère et moi on
parle
moi je serai plus tranquille quand même
si on faisait une une interview Mireille
Dumas pour voir si vous êtes bien
ensemble
[Musique]
comment ça va toutes les deux en ce
moment ça va ça va
Adamo vous voulez qu'on en parle un
petit peu ça serait bien non j'aimerais
bien vous trouvez ça vous trouvez ça
ringard que votre mère fasse un film à
partir d'Adamo moi j'aime bien
une reprise
Chantal vous avez raté quoi dans dans
l'éducation de Jane à part la coiffure
je ne te jette pas la pierre j'ai
moi-même une fille qui a les cheveux
rouges donc je te comprends tout à fait
et moi c'est pas qu'une mèche
je sais pas juste certainement peut-être
souvent culpabilise en disant on a dû
bosser beaucoup et pas les voir assez
c'est tout le temps les trucs en même
temps les instants que j'avais avec elle
je vais essayer d'en faire des instants
de qualité et de donner peut-être plus
que si j'avais passé toute la journée en
vacances je donnais probablement moins
quand j'étais 24 heures sur 24 avec elle
donnais moins que les deux ou trois
heures que j'avais pour elle donc voilà
on s'en sort non pas du tout je crois
pas en tout cas l'éducation sexuelle ça
s'est passé comment
les oreilles Jennifer les oreilles ta
mère et moi on parle les premières et
les premiers et moi sexuels de Jane et
ben un jour elle est venue elle m'en a
parlé j'ai pas eu de autant maintenant
maintenant
c'était en ca parce que la génération
n'était probablement pas la même autant
j'ai vu ensemble il y a pas eu de soucis
là-dessus ça s'est fait naturellement
mais elle était mineure quand même merde
l'amour
particulière bien je crois qu'il faut
aborder les choses franchement
maintenant Chantal ça vous gêne pas que
votre fille ait un piercing au sexe elle
a pas de piercing
vous êtes au courant
j'ai gueulé elle a quand même fait
je suis pas tombé noir
à Chantal que vous avez jamais osé dire
c'est le moment franchement c'est le
moment
je crois que non je crois que je lui dis
tout mais dis-lui
et voilà
je crois qu'il fallait que je suis à
choisi
franchement heureusement Chantal son
petit copain vous l'aimez bien sérieux
c'est un des musiciens du groupe je
trouve sympa
vous vous savez quand même le passé de
ce garçon
là c'est aussi terrible que ça c'était
affreux
sérieusement vous pensez que quand vous
serez encore plus âgé est-ce que Jane va
vous garder avec elle ou est-ce que vous
enverra dans une maison de retraite
[Applaudissements]
moi
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à la
fin
bien progressé là je crois que ça aide
quand même ça aide à la compréhension là
on a je crois qu'on a fait un grand pas
vous êtes parlé ce soir c'est la
première c'est la première fois depuis
deux jours
vous acceptez d'ouvrir le rideau
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu